we can refuse to think certain thoughts
look how often you have refused to think
a positive thought about yourself
well
you can also refuse to think a negative
thought about yourself too
it seems to me that everyone on this
planet that i know or have worked with
is suffering from self-hatred and guilt
to one degree or another
the more self-hatred and guilt we have
the less our life works
we find we have an inability to speak up
for ourselves
and we are always trying to please
others
or we may be angry and explosive all the
time
the less self-hatred and guilt we have
the better our lives work on all levels
this includes the health of the body too
it has been my experience that the very
bottom line for everyone i have worked
with is always
i'm not good enough
and we often add to this i don't do
enough
or
i don't deserve
does this sound like you
always saying or implying or feeling
that you are not good enough
but for whom
and according to whose standards
now if these negative beliefs are very
strong in you
then how can you possibly create a
loving joyous prosperous healthy life
somehow your subconscious beliefs would
always be contradicting these objectives
and making sure you do not obtain your
goals
i find that resentment criticism guilt
and fear
cause more problems in our bodies and in
our experiences than anything else
these feelings come from blaming others
and not taking responsibility
for our own lives
you see if we are all 100
responsible for everything in our lives
then there is no one to blame
whatever is happening out there is only
a mirror of our own inner thinking
i am not condoning other people's poor
behavior
but we must realize it is our beliefs
that attract to us
people that will treat us that way
if you find yourself saying everyone
always does such and such to me
criticizes me ignores me takes advantage
of me or abuses me
then this is your pattern
there is some thought in you that
attracts this behavior
on some internal level you believe you
deserve to be treated this way
or
you treat other people this way and it
is just coming back to you
whatever we give out mental physical or
verbal
will come back to us
when we no longer think or behave this
way
the other people will change their
behavior or they will go and do that to
someone else who believes they deserve
it
you will no longer be attracting the
experiences you say you do not want
whether we want to change a life
experience or a physical problem the
place to begin is to say so
literally say
i am willing to release the pattern
within me
that is creating this experience or this
condition
you can say this to yourself over and
over every time you think of your
illness
say this with me now
i am willing to release the pattern in
me
that has created this condition
the minute you say this affirmation you
are stepping out of the victim role
you are no longer helpless
you are acknowledging your own power
you are saying
i may not understand it
but somehow i am beginning to understand
that i contributed to creating this
problem and now i take my own power back
and i
am releasing it and letting it go
what a powerful statement to have your
subconscious mind supporting
as i said resentment of others criticism
of ourselves guilt over the past and
fear of the future are the most damaging
mental thought patterns we can have
this kind of internal dialogue creates
and maintains dis-ease in the body
these thoughts can destroy the body
fear can contribute to baldness
ulcers
colon problems and even painful feet
among other things
criticism as a permanent habit can often
lead to arthritis in the body
resentment long held
eats away at the body and becomes the
dis-ease we call cancer
guilt always looks for punishment and
creates pain we don't need any more
anger we need more self acceptance and
more self love
when we can accept ourselves right now
as we are right now without any
criticism or judgment
then we are truly loving ourselves and
the negative patterns must dissolve
if we wait until we have the new job
before we love ourselves
or if we wait until we lose weight
before we love ourselves
or if we wait until someone else loves
us before we love ourselves
then we are denying our existence right
now
if we wait until we become perfect
before we love ourselves
we waste our lives
we are already the perfect outer
expressions of our inner understanding
and we will change
but the changes we make when we love and
accept ourselves are always positive
always so let's release the anger and
all those negative beliefs about
ourselves and about life
and begin the process of accepting and
approving of who and what we are in the
here and now
we are always unfolding in the best way
we can
the knowledge and understanding that you
are already incorporating from this tape
will help you to change your life and
dissolve the negative patterns
no negative condition can remain in our
lives
when we truly love and accept ourselves
love is the healing power
love dissolves anger
love gets rid of guilt
love fades away fear
love for ourselves is the power that
heals us when we are very little
we learn how to feel about ourselves and
about life by the reactions of the
adults around us
now if you lived with frightened people
or with people who were very unhappy
then you learned a lot of negative
things about yourself and about life
you may still believe them
however this is not to blame our parents
for we are all victims of victims
and they could not possibly have taught
us anything they did not know
if your mother did not know how to love
herself
or your father did not know how to be
gentle and kind
then it would be impossible for them to
teach you to love yourself
or to be gentle and kind
your parents were doing the best they
could
with what they had been taught as
children
i also believe that we choose our
parents
each one of us decides to incarnate upon
this planet
at particular points in time and space i
believe we do this because we have
chosen to come here to learn a
particular lesson that will advance us
upon our spiritual
evolutionary pathway
choose our sex
our color
our country
and then we look around for the
particular set of parents who will
mirror
the pattern we are bringing in to work
on in this lifetime
often when we grow up we point our
fingers accusingly at our parents and
whimper you did it to me
but really
we chose them because they were perfect
for what we wanted to work on overcoming
as very little children we learn our
belief systems
and then we move through life creating
experiences to match our beliefs
look back in your own life
and notice how often you have gone
through the same experience
well i believe that you created those
experiences over and over
because they mirrored something that you
believed was true about yourself
it really doesn't matter how long we
have had a problem or how big it is
or how life-threatening it is
the point of power is always in the
present moment
this means
that what you have experienced during
your life
and up to this moment
you have created by your own thoughts
and beliefs of the past
however what you are choosing to think
and believe and say today right here and
right now
is creating your future
your current internal dialogue is
creating tomorrow next week next month
next year etc
notice what you are thinking at this
moment
do you want this thought to be creating
your future
is it negative or positive
just notice
and be aware
i'm not trying to create guilt for
anyone
nor to make anyone wrong
i am making us aware of what is going on
inside of us
many of us who create illness and
dis-ease are in fact totally out of
touch
with what is going on in our minds and
in our bodies
we only notice our bodies when we become
ill
or are in pain
if we do not know what is going on
inside of us how can we ever change
no matter what the problem is
the only thing we are ever dealing with
is a thought
and a thought can be changed
all our experiences are just outer
effects of our inner dialogue
even self-hatred
is only hating a thought you have about
yourself
you may have a thought that says i'm a
bad person
this thought produces a feeling and you
accept the feeling as true
however
if you eliminate the thought you won't
have the feeling
thoughts can be changed
change the thought and the feeling must
go
believe it or not we do choose our
thoughts
we may habitually think the same thought
over and over so often that it does not
seem that we are choosing the thought
but we did make the original choice
we can refuse to think certain thoughts
[Music]
look how often you have refused to think
a positive thought about yourself
well
you can also refuse to think a negative
thought about yourself
[Music]
it seems to me that everyone on this
planet that i know or have worked with
is suffering from self-hatred and guilt
to one degree or another
the more self-hatred and guilt we have
the less our life works
we find we have an inability to speak up
for ourselves
and we're always trying to please others
or we may be angry and explosive all the
time
the less self-hatred and guilt we have
the better our lives work
on all levels
this includes the health of the body too
let's talk about stress and being stress
free
this is the moment in which you are
either enjoying or not enjoying your
life
what you are thinking now is creating
the way you feel in your body now and
your experiences tomorrow
if you are stressing yourself out over
every little thing and making mountains
out of mole hills you will never find
inner peace
we talk a lot about stress these days
everyone seems to be stressed out by
something
stress seems to be a buzzword and we use
it to the point where i think it's a
cop-out i'm so stressed or this is so
stressful all this stress-stress stress
i think that stress is a fearful
reaction to life's constant changes
it is an excuse we often use for not
taking responsibility for our own
feelings
if we can put the blame out there on
someone or something then we can just
play the innocent victim
but being the victim doesn't make us
feel good and it doesn't change the
situation
often we are stressing ourselves because
we have our priorities mixed up
so many of us feel that money is the
most important thing in our lives but
this is not true
there's something far more important and
precious to us without which we could
not live
what is that
it's our breath
our breath is the most precious
substance in our lives and yet we
totally take for granted when we exhale
that our next breath will be there
if we did not take another breath we
would not last three minutes
now if the power that created us has
given us enough breath to last as long
as we shall live
can we not trust life that everything
else we need will also be supplied
when we trust life to take care of us
and all our little problems
then stress just melts away
you do not have time to waste on
negative thinking or emotions because
that only creates more of what you say
you don't want
if you are doing some positive
affirmations and you are not getting the
results you want then check to see how
often during the day you allow yourself
to feel bad to be upset
these emotions are probably exactly what
is frustrating you and delaying the
manifestation of your affirmations and
stopping the flow of your good
the next time you realize how stressed
you are ask yourself what is scaring you
stress is just fear it's that simple
you do not need to be afraid of life or
afraid of your own emotions
find out what you are doing to yourself
that is creating this fear within you
your inner goal is joy and harmony and
peace
harmony is being at peace with yourself
it is not possible to have stress and
inner harmony at the same time
when you are at peace you do one thing
at a time and you don't let things get
to you
when you feel stressed
do something to release the fear
breathe deeply or go for a brisk walk
remind yourself that
i am the only power in my world and i
create a peaceful loving joyful
fulfilling life
you want to move through life feeling
safe
don't give a little word like stress a
lot of power
don't use it as an excuse to create
tension in your body
nothing no person place or thing has any
power over you you are the only thinker
in your mind and it is your thoughts
that create your life
so train yourself to think thoughts that
make you feel good
that way you will always be creating
your life out of joy and in joy
joy always brings more to be joyous
about fear comes from not trusting the
process of life to be there for us
you know the most precious thing in our
life is our breath
if you did not take another breath you
would not last three minutes
yet you have such faith
that your next breath will be there
that you don't even think about it when
you exhale
now if the power that created us
has given us enough breath
to last for as long as we shall live
can we not begin to trust that the rest
will also be provided for us
the next time you are frightened
think about the abundance of air and say
i trust the process of life to take care
of me yes it is true that when you were
a child
there were some difficult times
times when you felt lonely
unwanted
and unloved
you were rejected
or abandoned
or even abused and humiliated
yes i know
there were some terrible times
of them may have been so awful you don't
even remember them
but the past
has no power over you
if you choose to live in the now
the point of power is in the present
moment
each moment
is a new beginning
and this moment
is a new beginning for you
right here and right now
[Music]
so let's take the past
all of it
and wrap it up in the pink of divine
love
and release it and let it go
[Music]
we affirm that you are now free
you are not your mother
nor her fears
you are not your father
nor his beliefs
[Music]
you are not any of the relatives
nor their opinions
you are not the teachers at school
nor their rigidity
and you are certainly not
the limitations of your early religious
upbringing
you are yourself
a divine magnificent expression of
life you are unique and special and
wonderful
one of a kind
since time began on this planet
there has never been another person like
you
and there never will be
therefore there is no competition
and no comparison
you have your own unique talents and
abilities
and your own special way of expressing
them
you are worthy of your own love
and your own self-acceptance
not because of what you have done
but just because you exist
it has been my experience that the very
bottom line for everyone i have worked
with is always
i'm not good enough
and we often add to this i don't do
enough or
i don't deserve
does this sound like you
always saying or implying or feeling
that you are not good enough
but for whom
and according to whose standards
now if these negative beliefs are very
strong in you
then how can you possibly create a
loving joyous prosperous healthy life
somehow your subconscious beliefs would
always be contradicting you
and making sure you do not obtain your
goals
i find that resentment criticism guilt
and fear
cause more problems in our bodies and in
our experiences than anything else
these feelings come from blaming others
and not taking responsibility
for our own lives
you see if we are all responsible for
everything that happens in our lives
then there is really no one to blame
whatever is happening out there is only
a mirror of our own inner thinking
i am not condoning other people's poor
behavior
but we must realize it is our beliefs
that attract to us people that will
treat us in that way
if you find yourself saying everyone
always does such and such to me
criticizes me ignores me takes advantage
of me or abuses me then this is your
pattern
there is some thought in you
that attracts this behavior
on some internal level you believe you
deserve to be treated this way or
you treat other people this way
and it is just coming back to you
whatever we give out
mental physical or verbal
will always come back to us
when we no longer think or behave in
this way
the other people will change their
behavior
or they will go and do that to someone
else who believes they deserve it you
will never find working a pleasure if
you hate your job or you can't stand
your boss
what a terrible affirmation that is
it will be impossible for you to ever
attract a great job with that belief
system
if you want to enjoy your time at work
then you must change your thinking
i'm a great believer in blessing with
love every person place and thing at the
workplace
begin with your current job
affirm that this job is merely a
stepping stone to far greater positions
you are in your current job because of
the things you believed in the past you
drew it to you by your thinking
perhaps you learned your attitude
towards work from your parents
no matter you can change your thinking
now
so bless with love your boss
your co-workers the location the
building the stairs or elevators the
rooms the furniture and each and every
customer
this creates a loving mental atmosphere
within you and the whole office will
respond to it
i have never understood the reasoning
behind putting down or berating others
at work
if you are an owner a manager or a
supervisor how can you possibly expect
to get the best work from others if they
are frightened or resentful
we all want to be appreciated
acknowledged and encouraged
if you support your employees and give
them respect then they will give you the
best work they can
now please don't believe that it is hard
to get a job that may be true for many
but it does not have to be true for you
you only need one job and your
consciousness will open the pathway for
you
don't have faith in fear
when you hear of negative trends in
business or in the economy immediately
affirm
that may be true for some but it is not
true for me i always prosper no matter
where i am or what is going on
people often ask me for the affirmations
to make their relationships at work be
smoother
in fact for many people this is a really
big issue in their lives
i am deeply aware that whatever i give
out comes back to me multiplied and this
is true everywhere including at work
in the workplace it is important to know
that every employee and employer has
been attracted by the action of love for
it's his and her divine right place here
and now at this point in time and space
divine harmony permeates us all and we
can all flow together in the workplace
in a most productive and joyous way
there aren't any problems that don't
have solutions there aren't any
questions without answers
choose to go beyond the problem to seek
the divine right action solution to any
discord that may seem to appear
be willing to learn from any discord or
confusion as it comes up
it's important to release all blame and
turn within to seek the truth
and be willing to release whatever
pattern may be in your consciousness
that has contributed to the situation
know that you are successful in all that
you do
you're inspired and productive
you serve others willingly and gladly
divine harmony reigns supreme within and
around you and within and around each
and every person in your workplace
when you know and declare that it's
possible to successfully operate in the
workplace according to divine principles
then divine love brings to you those who
can be helped by that which you so
lovingly do
now if you like your job but feel you're
not getting paid enough then bless your
current salary with love
expressing gratitude for what you do
have enables it to grow
and absolutely no more bitching about
the job or co-workers
your consciousness put you where you are
now your changing consciousness can lift
you to a better position
you can do it
during your work day there are a number
of things you can do to release tension
here are a few ideas
one
before you go to work every day do this
simple exercise just sit comfortably and
concentrate on your breath
whenever you notice thoughts coming in
gently bring your awareness back to your
breath
give yourself at least 10 or 15 minutes
to dwell in the silence each day there
is nothing difficult or tricky to this
and it's worth taking the time
two
write or type this affirmation and put
it where you can see it at work
my job is a peaceful haven
i bless my job with love
i put love in every corner
and my job lovingly responds with warmth
and comfort
i am at peace
when you start to think about your boss
say this affirmation to yourself
i only give out that which i wish to
receive
my love and acceptance of others is
mirrored to me in every way
refuse to be limited in any way by human
mind thinking
your life can be filled with love and
joy because your work is a divine idea
remember to say to yourself every day
before going to work
no matter where i am there is only
infinite good infinite wisdom infinite
harmony and love whenever someone is in
pain i know they have created a lot of
guilt for themselves
chronic pain comes from unrelenting
guilt
often so buried that we are not even
aware of it anymore
this guilt must be dissolved before the
pain can be eliminated
guilt is a totally useless emotion
it never makes anyone feel better
nor does it change a situation
your sentence is now over
let yourself out of prison
anger combined with guilt often
contributes to accidents
the degree of physical damage lets us
know how severely we felt we needed to
be punished and how long the sentence
where this pain occurs in the body gives
us a clue to which area of life we feel
guilty about
critical people often attract a lot of
criticism
because it is their pattern to criticize
they are often cursed with perfectionism
the need to be perfect at all times in
every situation
do you know of anyone on this planet who
is perfect
i do not
why do we set up standards that say that
we have to be super person in order to
be barely acceptable
that is such a heavy burden to carry
when i was a little girl i had a very
difficult childhood
my parents divorced when i was 18 months
i was raped when i was five i became a
battered child and grew up in the
depression
my mother was very much a victim
and my stepfather constantly expressed
his own brutalized childhood
i grew up having a lot of resentment
i had to create cancer in my own body
before i was willing to begin to release
that resentment
i am certainly not condoning the
behavior of any of the people who
mistreated me
however for me to spend a lifetime just
running the old movie feeling blame and
anger and resentment is not doing me any
good in the present moment
i learned that resentment only eats away
at me
and it did
in my case holding on to old blame and
feeling resentful for all that they did
to me helped to create my disease
releasing and letting go
helped me to heal myself
the past is over and done
we cannot change that now
we can change our attitude toward the
past and our thoughts toward the past
how foolish for us to punish ourselves
in the present moment because someone
else hurt us in the long ago past
it's not worth it
i often say to people who have deep
resentment patterns please
begin to dissolve the resentment now
when it is relatively easy
don't wait until you're under the threat
of a surgeon's knife
and you have to cope with panic too
it is vital that we release foolish
outmoded or negative ideas and beliefs
that do not support us and nourish us
our concepts of ourselves and of life
and of god must support us
not negate us
no matter what our disease if we choose
to believe that we are helpless victims
and that it is all hopeless
then the universe will support us in
that belief and we will just go down the
drain
when people come to me with a problem i
don't care what it is poor health lack
of money
unfulfilling relationships or stifled
creativity
there is only one thing i ever work on
and that is
loving the self
i find that when we really love and
accept and approve of ourselves exactly
as we are
then everything in life flows it is
impossible to really love
until we have forgiven
as the course in miracles says
would you rather be happy and well
or would you rather be right
in front of you
see a small stage
and on this stage
place the person
you resent the most
it could be past
or present
living
or dead
[Music]
when you see this person clearly
forgive them
say to them
i forgive you
for not being the way i wanted you to be
i forgive you
and i set you free
then begin
to see good things happening to them
things that would be meaningful to them
[Music]
see them smiling
and happy
they are still smiling as you allow them
to fade away
now notice a prison door opening before
you
feel
chains and shackles drop away from you
as you walk out into the sunshine of
life
[Music]
they are free
and now you are free
if you want some amazing motivation with
louise hay check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i'm not talking about
vanity or arrogance because that is not
love that's always fear
i'm talking about just really respecting
and appreciating this incredible